-Welcome back to the show,
Seth. How are ya?
-I'm good. How are you, Seth
-I'm good.
I know you're in L.A. now
but were you in New York
right before this all started.
Were you at least behaving
safely when you were
in New York back in February
-I was trying --
I was at a giant charity event
So it was hard to behave safel
and it was just --
there was like rumblings of it
in the air.
So I, at moments, would just
hand myself over to
normal behavior and shook
200,000 people's hands
at the event, and, and
Martha Stewart was there
and I don't want to, you know,
support any conspiracy theorie
but she had just gotten back
from China where the virus was
at that moment very active
And she left
because of the virus,
and we're sharing this
information,
the face-to-face conversatio
at which moment I was like
Martha Stewart,
back away from me, please.
But, yeah. It was --
but if I was to get it
from Martha Stewart it would
have been completely --
-Oh, yeah.
-The best.
-It would be that artisan
vibe.
-Exactly.
-Yes.
You, this movie, which is
fantastic, is based on
a short story by Simon Ric
who also wrote the screenpla
I think he was a writer
at "SNL."
And I had forgotten a couple
things, one,
that he wrote your monologue the
first time you hosted "SNL,"
and two that you were only 2
years old the first time
you hosted "SNL" which is
incredibly young.
-Yeah, I was.
And I think Simon was actually
around the same age.
But, although he looked maybe
years old, I think.
-Yeah. He was --
he maybe looks 23 now.
-Exactly! Yeah.
It was really a lot to see
that my monologue was not even
conceived of
and Saturday afternoon I think
was approaching and, again
I was a 23-year-old young ma
who grew up watching "SNL"
and wanted to
make a good impression.
I was really, really, really
nervous, and then Simon.
This kid, this guy who seemed,
again, like a child,
came up and handed me
this thing.
Hey, man, I wrote this.
And I read it.
It was like word-for-word
perfect.
I literally didn't change on
thing and I remember thinking,
if this guy ever writes a movi
about a guy who gets pickled
I'd love to be in it!
-[ Laughter ]
I went with -- you know,
after working there a long time,
When I went back and hosted
had this whole new respect
for what we put hosts throug
because there was this sense of,
oh, the monologue,
we can push it off,
we can push it often,
forgetting that
when you actually have to host a
show and it's the first time
you're gonna talk to the
audience,
you'd really like to have it
under control by like
Monday, Tuesday, actually.
-You like to have some sense
of what the first things you'r
going to be expected to say are.
But, yeah.
But I've since --
it is Lorne who said we don't do
the show because it's read
we do the show because it'
Saturday and 11:30.
Which are very impactful words
on me.
-So impactful, you said it
maybe 1 million times.
-Exactly.
I apply it to non-"SNL" things
which I don't know if it works
but I think that it does.
-Your monologue, for those who
don't remember,
because a long time ago now,
was the idea behind it,
was you reading a monologue yo
had written when you were 13
that always wanted to do if yo
ever hosted "SNL"
but you were actually doin
stand-up as a 13-year-old.
This is not a crazy idea.
What was your material like when
you were 13?
-Um, it was 13-year-old stuff.
It was, if I would write about
my grandparents.
That was the first joke I ever
wrote. It was my grandparents.
I would go watch "TGIF" at their
house every Friday
while my family went to
synagogue
and I didn't want to go
and they would argue about -
they were both deaf and they
would argue with each other.
And those were my first joke
I wrote was like
my grandparents
arguing with each other.
And not knowing the other person
was arguing about.
-This is a, this is a movi
about our ancestors,
grandparents,
great-grandparents.
The premise of the film is tha
you play both yourself
in modern day
and yourself from 100 years ago.
Your great-great-grandfather
who was pickled
and preserved
at a pickle factory.
And so basically you're playin
two versions of yourself,
but one from a century earlier
-Yes. It was weird.
Um, it was not, it was not
a choice I made lightly,
because, yeah.
There's not -- you know,
I think of a spotty traditio
of actors playing
two roles in a film.
But I honestly felt like i
really helped the narrative.
That convinced me, honestly,
in the end.
And this idea of, you know
if we met our grandparents
when they were the same age of
us, what would they think of us?
Would they like us?
My grandparents barely tolerated
me as my grandparents.
My grandfather was a tough man
he was a plumber.
He was in the war.
You know?
And he had no time for my,
my modern, you know,
my modern crap.
It was not entertaining for him.
I remember one time as a kid m
toenail was too long
and I asked him
to help me cut it
and he ripped my entire
toenail off.
-I was also, there's a very --
a great amount of heart
in this film as well.
-Yeah.
-It's a incredibly silly
concept.
There's fantastic jokes,
but there's this idea of,
can a previous generation be
proud of the next generation
even though they're doing
different things
and different accomplishments.
I read an interview with you
today where you were sayin
that your grandparent were never
that impressed
with your success
but still be super psyched
to go to a McDonald's.
-Yeah they loved.
And they would steal napkins
That was my grandparents.
My grandmother stole everythin
and that was to her, like,
her greatest accomplishments
were the things, like,
we would go to dinner, and
literally, you'd see her
being like,
this is a nice plate.
And then you go to her house the
next day,
and she would have the plate
because --
she would put it in her purse.
So they really coveted thing
like napkins and plates.
So the fact I had, like a whol
closet full of paper towel rolls
was very impressive to my
grandparents.
But the fact
that I was in movies,
they would always be like,
you think you're a big shot?
You think you're a big shot?
That was -- that was,
their favorite expression.